ben shapiro host one of America's top
podcast the Ben Shapiro show he's the
author of the book the right side of
history and we're happy to have him on
set tonight in Los Angeles Ben it's
great to see you thank you I I kept a
straight face for you there is there are
so many levels here but I do believe
that this is the end of the beta
O'Rourke phenomenon yeah I think he's
dosed what are the lessons that we
should draw from what we just saw well I
think that you can run in the moderate
lane as the Bobby Kennedy candidate so
long as there's not anything newer on
the Block Buddha judge came along and
drank his milkshake and he had some
intersectional credibility the problem
for bado
is that he happened to be straight and
also white just like Bobby Kennedy was
buddha's edge is gay so therefore he
takes precedence also he speaks more
languages like Norwegian which is a
language that is very much in vogue with
the media these days he doesn't just
play guitar he also plays piano and he
does it with with Ben Folds Five and the
whole deal so buddha josh has basically
stolen all of his momentum and i think
you're right i mean i think bado is
toast here speaking norwegian and
playing the piano oh and I'm being
sincere are actually impressive that a
cool we used to do for sure and I'm
impressed by them but they're not really
policy prescriptions they're not ideas
that are going to improve America and
neither is who you sleep with relevant
to run the country as far as I can tell
or any of these criteria meaningful so
like where's the part we get to debate
their ideas for the country well the
problem is obviously that there is only
one thought leader in the Democratic
Party right now and that's Bernie
Sanders and what you're seeing is a
bunch of candidates who are attempting
to steer into the Bernie Sanders Lane
and there's no room in that lane Bernie
Sanders has occupied that entire lane
you talk about ideas candidates the one
candidate who keeps shouting ideas from
the rooftops is of course our Native
American candidate Elizabeth Warren who
keeps spouting ideas every five minutes
there's a new policy prescription why
isn't anyone paying attention to me and
the answer is because you are in Bernie
Sanders is Lane he is the thought leader
in this lane well in the moderate Lane
there are no thought leaders they're
just a bunch of people with platitudes
Biden is presumably the thought leader
but Joe Biden doesn't have enough
thoughts to be a thought leader and so
who exactly is going to come along and
occupy that Lane while still being able
to win over the woke intersectional base
of the Democratic Party whoever does
that has a possibility at the nomination
right now booty judge can do that only
in so far as he can speak the platitudes
that sound moderate but when he's
actually pegged down as you've noted
he's just as far left as Bernie Sanders
emits a guy telling us what a great
Christian is who's for abortion up until
birth and for sex selection spare me
your Christian talk please it's absurd
I'm Destructo by Bernie could be the one
guy mean I want to have a conversation
about ideas because I think it's
important and clearly we need to make
some changes to the way the country is
going but Bernie doesn't really seem to
be an ideas candidate when you listen to
him he almost never says anything
unlike Elizabeth Warren he never says
anything interesting why is that well I
mean I think that his ideas are so
radical but they are consistent and so
everybody has followed him out to the
fringe so you can shout medicare-for-all
and what you'll see is every Democrat
then pay homage to Medicare for all
footnote we don't really want Medicare
for all we want sort of a gradual istic
plan that may achieve Medicare for all
sometime in the future but everybody is
trying to imitate Bernie Bernie as the
guy who is really running this race
Bernie's almost in a position right now
that Trump was in in 2016 where
everybody in the Democratic Party who's
running is afraid to take him off
because they hope that eventually he'll
collapse and they'll get his support but
he's riding at 25 to 30% in virtually
all of the polls that support is
extraordinarily durable I don't think
that it's going anywhere and so he can
just steer that way and he could win
Iowa he could win New Hampshire he could
do well in California in New York
there's a reason that Democrats are
running scared of Bernie and what is
puzzling to me is that they are so
interested in what the journalist on
Twitter say this kind of echo chamber in
the media say that they won't just go to
where the mainstream of their own party
is which is the moderate area right Joe
Biden is a terrible candidate he's
actually leading in most of these polls
because he is perceived as a moderate
totally true but that's true of a toe
and bootie judge by the way the reason
both of them were doing well for a
moment there was because they are both
perceived as moderate with all of the
platitudes and then when you get down to
policy it turns out that they want to be
more like Bernie then like Biden nobody
in the Democratic Party actually has the
stones to run as a moderate inside the
Democratic Party even though it's
probably the best possible way for them
to win the nomination and and I think
you're absolutely right
and your diagnosis is that they are
captive of social media and that's why I
think they're captive of social media I
think they're captive of the
intersectional woek base I think they're
afraid that they're going to be
held hostage to the dictates of the New
York Times editorial board and people
suggesting that they're not woke enough
if they don't pay homage to the latest
flavor slavery reparations or whatever
it is today I think the person who gives
the finger to that mob gets the support
of millions I think that's right and
then has a good shot in the general
right but I don't think any of them have
the actual how we get my support I mean
if someone were to stand up and say you
know what I'm gonna take an orders from
you how's that sound
I don't all mostly don't care what the
person is for I'd probably vote for him
I'm so desperate for that I mean that is
why if a Democrat actually were able to
do that they would they wouldn't
sweeping support but they can't do that
it's but we've been saying this for
years all you have to do is not be crazy
and they can't stop they just get so
good Ben Shapiro great to see you thank
you see you dude